it's been exactly a year since CCP
showed off their virtual reality space
dogfighter EVR for the first time at fan
fest 2013 now returning to the show is
Eve Valkyrie we managed to get our hands
on it or heads in it we played it so
here's everything you need to know about
a Valkyrie Unreal Engine 4 is N and
unity is out as the game engine of
choice the impact of which is clear as
space day in the visuals just take a
look at this brand-new unreal gameplay
versus the older Unity stuff
newly designed ships increased details
UI updates particle effects unlike
seeing all shine in the Unreal tech this
is our first ever built that uses the
Unreal 4 engine as Valkyries maturing
and we're understanding better what we
want to achieve we decided that Unreal
forfeit it's us as a team there's a
really great sense of the space inside
the cockpit if you were able to fly
close by one of your wingmen you can see
a lot of the detail that we put into
that particular fighter the environment
in which you're flying around is almost
entirely in you as well
all of this was shown off on the
brand-new oculus development kit - which
has a resolution of 960 by 1080 per eye
a refresh rate of up to 75 Hertz and
covers a hundred degrees of your field
of view and I gotta say I was pretty
blown away we also got our first glimpse
of what the heck this story is gonna be
all about you play as one of the
Valkyrie led by run who by the way is
voiced by Katee Sackhoff aka Battlestar
Galactica Starbuck holy I know right
anyway these Valkyrie our breakaway
mercenary faction they're guns for hire
seeking profit or vengeance I should
have said frak
I apologize that's cool ibly chief
norris Casey however these Valkyrie are
no ordinary humans they are immortal
snatched from death in the final moments
and cloned they are genetically enhanced
for combat and fly without fear or mercy
the former mascara through swill be the
voice in your ear throughout the game
delivering instructions mission details
and general guidance details surrounding
game modes are still thin on the ground
however we played a three-minute
team-based dogfight where we needed to
shoot down enemy pirates to give our
salvage team a chance to recover
anything of value from the aftermath of
a recent space battle Valkyrie will also
come with a standard fare of multiplayer
choices there are a variety of ship
rolls from faster fighters heavily
armored assault craft to tactical
support ships built around a
rock-paper-scissors model all of their
own strengths and weaknesses these will
also be customizable with loadouts
boosts and more advanced ships and
low-dose will also be unlockable as your
skills grow
speaking of skills your Valkyrie pilot
will also be able to climb through the
ranks as a new conscript gaining
experience and reputation throughout the
game missions
so there you have it everything you need
to know about Eve Valkyrie the game is
set for release at some point in the
future on both PC and ps4 and will
undoubtedly be making an appearance at
both III in June and games come in
August we will of course be at both
events to bring you all the latest so
for more on Eve Valkyrie make sure you
keep your eyes on games.com